yeah welcome to this video playing a new
game here five-minute against backdoor
threat and I really hope to not lose the
game I mean you regularly i usually
don't hope to lose games but i lost the
last four in a row which is a commonly
known as the Audie like this German car
symbol I don't intend to make it the
Olympic rings yeah I've got a Carol can
exchange variation not the most
spectacular opening okay come on I'm
losing all my games let's see can I have
some funny I was g5g for okay well that
should i do that let's see what what
happens AR yeah yeah yeah okay maybe
here and Bishop c5 one night is seven
simply I he's got he's got Knight f3
coming or should I play and it's not
really working let's let's do this okay
okay okay I don't mind that really it
should should be a playable position mmm
i have 6 9 h tix lady h6 at five from
them just good
uh-huh didn't expect that at all okay I
thought he was playing for c4 or
something opening the position and now
he sees doing that it seems this one are
on a mr. base seven isn't a threat I
always have okay I always have enough
play I wanted to say was rookie aid and
so on but first I can go here and attack
the edge pool so just this young Andrew
k2 why not
hmm yeah it looks fairly active for
black p2 is attacked and I've got a good
healthy structure the only slide various
this opposition of rook and and king
should I play yeah let's not spend too
much time rock edge form some covering
this c4 idea maybe maybe a good move
want to try to not fall to be too much
behind on the clock
hmm where do you go
maybe here night b7 that's not really
great i mean i can take 2 C 3 for
instance can take C 3 for instance yeah
getting the porn back end I'm having
quite a good structure here if five
Emmys got four week pawns and I've got
no bleep on that how does he even
protect others 93 is another additional
motif
okay I grabbed this him and he tried for
some some counterplay night here I can
play Knight h6 if everything else fails
I've got 96 97 97 and F hmm yeah okay
should I am even advanced here why not
actually why not maybe I can set up a
meeting that here you can always dream
night eh for some some stuff like that
Queen King f4 night h4 would be would be
close to mate yeah but I can I can I can
still play this here
I have no way to meet him this is not
working no not f5 please not a 50 came
getting the knight to e5 we can play I
can play this ah I can play this didn't
think about that still
ah I f4 check on 95
you don't see another moose holy smokes
this is a check need to go here and then
you can even take a nest havena really
amazing by the way it's rocky too lovely
to look II 2g to mate how does he
prevent that f5 f5 this is me tried who
could she to meet thank God I didn't
really wanted to lose the fifth game in
a row ah detected okay yeah what the
heck he really got got some some play
him yeah i simply i forgot about King g3
nonsense again I can just play here and
it support for nothing it's not nice on
age 6 I know but this is the only
weakness and if this is covered it fits
over simply yeah okay well thanks for
watching